so Bridges and main roads are in tiptop
shape this morning across Metro
Vancouver and the Lower Mainland but
where it starts to get icy and dicey are
the side streets getting into the
neighborhoods where homes are there's a
lot of snow to deal with with
temperatures plummeting to well below
zero overnight the snow that came down
yesterday is starting to freeze drivers
are being warned that they will need to
stay vigilant heading out of the roads
this morning sidewalks could also be
slick which could create slippery
conditions for pedestrians we're not not
out of the woods yet there's another
chance of snow and a risk of freezing
rain this afternoon across the Lower
Mainland and on the island which can
make for a treacherous or messy
afternoon commute for anyone out on the
roads is going to be hectic on the road
if you do need to travel make sure that
you do travel with the the Right Tires
you are prepared for the trip leave with
extra time but again exercise staying at
home if you can so there are less cars
on the road which means plows were able
to get around and do their job but again
with the risk of freezing rain and snow
tonight in parts of Metro Vancouver and
the Lower Mainland people are being
urged to stay home Emily liton Global
News in Suri